heyo welcome to new rock stars ant-man
of the wasp 423 summit of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
that's it theaters boy howdy is it a fun
time is it a kind of sad kind of
exciting thing about all this we're
about to reach the end of this saga I
had a lot of the characters that we
spent the past 10 years with will be
retiring when we're moving into a new
direction with new characters new
settings and new villains who will our
remaining heroes have to fight to
protect the universe are we finally
going to be able to go back to our comfy
quiet lives probably not we've got some
big boys and girls waiting in the wings
especially after that Disney Fox merger
that goes through later this year make
it happen
there are many lists of characters out
there on the interwebs talking about who
they would want for phase 4 and beyond
but let's take all the hints and teasers
from the MCU and apply it to the list of
characters from the comics and come up
with a definitive list of villains that
we couldn't see in phase 4 of the MCU in
no particular order
let us begin first up number 1 Kang the
Conqueror who is Kang you're asking this
is Krang that's Kang this is Krang that
skank you're welcome well these most
famously as of late in Avengers level
threat from all across time
yeppers he's a time travel villain plus
he's got super strength longevity zlib
forever and so many more powers he's
appeared in Marvel Comics in many
different forms over the years and he's
always kind of got a new look and a new
agenda going for him the reason I feel
like he would be the logical next step
is because of the teases we've seen a
name in the wasp yes the time vortex is
signaling the time travel in a way as
possible in the MCU outside of the time
stone but also Cassie Cassie and this
movie teases that she wants to partner
up with her dad and go and fight crime
well fun fact Cassie eventually does
grow up in the comics to be a hero my
favorite version of her hero persona is
stature eventually she's a part of The
Young Avengers who also has a teammate
named iron lad interesting an Iron Man
like young hero who is eventually
revealed to be king from the future see
all these complicated stories already
spiraling out of this number 2 if you
wanted to go smaller potatoes for our
next big-time villain and
not go all universe ending event II
maybe you could turn to one of Spidey's
villains especially the one that has
such a big impact on the Marvel Comics
universe that's right I'm talking about
Norman Osborn now I know we've seen two
versions of Norman so far but for good
reason he's one of the most important
characters to Peter Parker and I know
Marvel Studios and if they had their
writers worked on infinity war in Civil
War on Captain America Winter Soldier
they could really turn him into a real
powerhouse now imagine this after
infinity War part 2 we realized that the
sokovia cords aren't really working we
need a better solution in the UN
handpicks new individuals to make a
better Avengers team who could protect
them against cosmic and
extra-dimensional
threats and who better to lead them than
a powerful influential businessman who's
willing to put his life on the line much
like Tony Stark
that's where Norman comes in and this
could be very similar to his run as the
leader of the Dark Avengers actually
this is where the iron Patriot suit was
introduced fun fact this would also lead
to a team of villains to face off
against our heroes much like the Masters
of evil or you could possibly go with
something closer to the sinister six
those are just some extra ideas but
since we had the tease of someone buying
Avengers tower in spider-man homecoming
and Sonny Bert's working for someone
else in a man and the wasp it would be
interesting to learn that Norman has
been working in secret for quite some
time in the MCU number three let's go
back to our huge cosmic level threats
for a second and take a turn to the
darker tones I know we might be a little
tired of our superhero films trying to
be serious for darker but imagine if the
MCU took a turn towards the horror genre
now bear with me enter Annihilus
Annihilus was introduced way back in the
60s in the Fantastic Four comics but
with the merger I could see this
character playing a very big role in the
cosmic side of Marvel with the success
of guardians the galaxy vol 1 into
Marvel has teased expanding their cosmic
side if they want to start building out
their Guardians roster possibly the Nova
Corps and Nova the hero and Adam
warlocks introduction I Annihilus would
be a very good enemy for them why ask
well the annihilation storyline of
course now in annihilation it's about
how Annihilus invades our universe from
the negative zone where he is king of
course
why wouldn't he be in his Armada
conquers planet after planet consuming
just about everything this caused the
formation of the guardians of the galaxy
that you know and love and while
expanding the cosmic side of the MC you
could also involve our earthbound hero
specifically Captain Marvel and Thor
number four this is the guy that gets
the most votes from everyone everywhere
even me Doctor Doom you've seen again
two live action versions of Doctor Doom
so I understand if you're not too
excited but he is an extremely
compelling and complicated villain
that's why we keep trying to make him
good most of the time while he is
extremely egocentric and willing to go
to great violent lengths to achieve his
goal he really does care for his country
when it comes down to it he saved the
multiverse from total collapse
no sure he did turn himself into the god
of that universe after that even though
he didn't need to but he did do
something good kind of he's complex and
have done right it could be an extremely
popular character for fans and number
five Dormammu now this is lower than
Doctor Doom purely because I didn't
quite love him in the Doctor Strange
solo movie but he wasn't a bad adversary
really also strange didn't defeat this
god of another universe he just made a
deal with him Dormammu made a similar
deal with strange in the past in the
comics and he usually figures out a
multitude of ways to manipulate his way
back into our universe by influencing or
even possessing individuals and giving
them power he's even gone up against
embodiments of our multiverse and one
yeah so he's no joke now seeing a threat
so large in cosmic attacking universe
definitely sounds like a threat that
would need more than just a group of
sorcerers possibly a team to help out
let me know what you think now I didn't
want to make this top six list so here's
my honorable mention Magus this is the
embodiment of all the negative parts of
Adam warlock / Adam warlocks eventual
future self depending on who the
storyteller is now Adam warlock has been
teased for guardians the galaxy vol 3
he's basically space Jesus he's with an
insanely powerful cosmic comic-book
character but so as Magus Megas is his
opposite he wouldn't be an easy threat
to take down and it could lead to him
possibly organizing other cosmic
societies against earth and the
Guardians but there you have it what do
you think of my definitive list of
possible phase 4 villains who do you
think is the next logical villain to be
picked let me know in the comments
down below but make sure you like
subscribe check out our other videos and
hit that notification icon to stay up to
date when we release stuff sending your
ideas on Twitter at Sam basher I'll see
you guys next time bye bye
[Music]